we've been banned from Airbnb oh really
yeah there's a reason there's do you
want another reason
so do you remember in Seattle remember
Chaz yeah okay chop yeah yeah
so what happened is and do you remember
Raz Simone was like he was like the
warlord yeah
then we did some research on him and we
found out that Raz Simone uh actually
had an Airbnb and like got all these
grants from the government so what we
did was we sent our producers down to
Chas we rented out as Airbnb and
declared it new Chas oh my God and spray
painted new Chas and all this stuff and
we actually handed out for sure we
actually handed out party uh Flyers his
ice maker come join new Chas oh my God
and he found it and actually our guys
got chased out so this whole live stream
was come to New chats which was Airbnb
yeah the Socialist gun club uh showed up
and chased them out with Bingo if
they're in jazz oh my god well and he
found it so mid show he actually tweeted
us I think is how we found him he was on
Instagram where he's like you guys are
big funny you know like yeah he actually
had a good sense of humor about it but
then he got us banned from Airbnb oh
so this is his yeah this is Razz
Simone's Airbnb yeah Raz Simone and so
you can see why they wouldn't want us on
there yeah we didn't actually spray
paint it by the way we just did a really
good Photoshop good and we know because
they showed up he was like dude don't
he's a guys don't worry it was Photoshop
it was fake all right that was good
because the whole idea was it's really
easy to say this is our autonomous Zone
when you're vandalizing other people's
crap so we just said let's go to your
Airbnb that's brilliant and uh yeah so
you're permanently banned from that I
think we had a couple accounts banned
from Uber
um anything else I know you're obviously
very against big Tech anything with uh
with meta Instagram Tick Tock well yeah
we've been suspended so that's how I met
my half asian lawyer Bill Richmond was
it was there he's only half asian
if he's half Jew then he's killing it
yeah exactly yeah it's like the yin yang
of fantastic I want to get one but he he
met me uh through was it Engadget or
Gizmodo I always get it wrong I think
it's Gizmodo so it was like this article
that went out and we were doing millions
and millions of reads on the website
just a lot of credit.com was like it's
just a news site as well and um what
happened is all of a sudden it just got
throttled and we we just couldn't uh
generate any type of traffic anymore and
we even a b tested it on other pages and
noticed oh if we run it on someone
else's page it does well we run it on
our page it doesn't get any clicks and
so then an article was released from
Gizmodo or and get it what did I say I
don't know it sounds better it was the
code baked in where there was a leak
from the in from an Insider saying like
yeah it was the Ted Cruz for president
the Chris Kyle Foundation Breitbart and
me one of these things is not like the
other right but because pound for pound
it was all organic traffic we didn't
have nearly the budget and so then I
call my friend who was a group he was a
good friend of mine uh and he was a
Harvard Law grad he's like that's not
really the law I do but here's this guy
who might this guy named Bill Richmond
half asian lawyer and then I talked with
him and he thinks like yeah this is
another conservative right there are
these wannabe Martyrs we're like I'm
being suspended or whatever it is like
well that's because you threatened to
kill someone's dog you know whatever
yeah not all but I'm saying sometimes so
uh it goes okay I'll call you and then
he calls me back he goes wow uh yeah
actually looks like there's code in
there and there's actually quotes from
The Insider and they actually there were
screenshots of them removing us from
organic trending so we couldn't trend on
Facebook couldn't trend on Instagram uh
YouTube we've run into it and keep in
mind nothing we do is that crazy sure
some of the jokes are crazy but it's fun
it's PG-13 yeah you know what I mean it
really is for the like you're talking
about guys who are pro-second Amendment
Pro First Amendment Pro yeah pro-life
you know conservative Christians who
maybe every now and then the joke
Ruffles some feathers a little bit too
much but we've had run-ins with all of
them that's why it's you're talking
about millions of dollars just in legal
fees because we had to bake it into our
business model but I think if you're not
pushing an envelope like if like just
scratching and trying to put then it's
not fun like you know what I mean it's
just boring that's part of this not
doing it just to be vulgar or just be
like oh look what they're doing I like I
think the funniest ones are when you're
like oh where it's fun and you make
them think and you're like oh he's
kind of right yeah so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]